-Guys, we're in the middle
of the NFL season --
gosh, I love football --
and this Sunday night's game has
the Dallas Cowboys facing off
against the Minnesota Vikings.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Vikings!
-Okay. Now, as you know,
at the end of every season,
they give out awards,
like Most Valuable Player.
But they also give out awards
during the season.
-Do they really?
-Yeah, I'll show you
what I mean.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Superlatives." Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ "Superlatives" ♪
♪♪
-Our first player is
from the Cowboys.
It's...
[ Cheering and applause ]
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Where is it?"
-Next up from the Vikings is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-What?
-I didn't know they had those.
-Next up from the Cowboys is...
Yeah, he was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Vikings is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Just because your baby's
nine months old
doesn't mean he can't be jacked.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Cowboys is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Next up from the Cowboys is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter, oohs, and applause ]
Next up from the Cowboys is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"No."
Next up from the Vikings is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
-And, finally,
from the Cowboys is...
He was voted...
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you go. Those are
your "Superlatives."